voilà ce concert l'adjudant-chef kelly
est le troisième membre avoir été
attaqué
[Musique]
les trois tireurs sont morts
sa femme a été également tués
ils n'ont plus qu'à espérer qu'il ne
survive pas
pourquoi ces deux longs à l'homme le
plus dangereux et le plus efficace qu on
est sur le terrain
[Musique]
ils m'ont tout pris
c'était des attaques étrangères sur
notre territoire et devons réagir
je vais régler cette histoire
il ya une partie de moi
que rien apaisera
une partie de moi que rien ni personne
n'arrêtera
aucun remords
ça ne vous a pas effleuré que john kelly
et pu faire quelque chose dont on est
pas capable
il faut avoir une certaine ouverture
d'esprit pour analyser cette situation
[Musique]
- non pas censé avoir survécu marion